[Musique]
alors quand tu t'appelles tu te dis moi
je lance une petite chaîne sur youtube
où je demande aux gens dans la rue leur
meilleur de la pensée je vais demander
un petit peu à chacun la blague
inavouables est-ce que tu connais une
blague un peu comme ça stigmatisant
pourquoi pourquoi on rigole que des
cours oui parce que la blessure
donc tu peux me la faire parce que je
crois que j'ai pas tu vas bien
l'entendre et la voilà quand on a un
court bain mais bon c'est pas contre
vous c'est ce que pense le rêve de tout
un du coup on rigole c'est pourquoi on
vient à gérard benoit jeu de combat
vas-y tu fais jamais d'un v12 a
contraint près de rabat mais ces cadeaux
je parle j'avais vu ce qui fige en font
des blagues sur les robots boss et pour
la chaîne youtube c'est quoi non mais tu
bégaye maintenant je souhaite avant
vente et de support
j'ai un peu pressés dans lequel j'ai
compris a doublé ces comprimés ainsi le
petit koné combien avec un seul cri
encore bonjour
du coup voilà vu que maintenant il ya
une personne de takeshi magie
ben
[Musique]
saliya mois la débine armand en fait est
un parent bakwa sais pas si c'est un
noir un chinon et un arabe dans un avion
et j'ai décrit par des supports ouais
les chaînes de blague c'est un méchant
mais je te dirai ça va peut-être les
faire rire vos bras citant le renault a
acquis non mais je connais pas un blog
en fait je n'ai pas d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]